but first a moratorium on the
constitution that's the focus of
tonight's angle
for four years democrats complained that
president trump had no regard for the
rule of law
or respect for the constitution i hope
there are at least
enough senators here who understand that
america
is careening over a constitutional cliff
to fight back against
lawless overreach by an out-of-control
president donald trump is lawless that
he
he believes he is above the law the
breaking of the law is
trump's point he is proud of his
lawlessness
well well well where are all those
principal democrats now and i have
principled in quotes
now this week joe biden and his party
erased all doubt as to whether they
actually respect our constitution
the supreme court's authority and the
principle of separation of powers well
the short answer they couldn't care less
president biden defied a clear directive
from the supreme court
on the question of whether the
administration's coveted eviction
moratorium
was unconstitutional now it was kind of
a quirky deal it was a 5-4 decision
and the court decided to leave the
moratorium in place
but in a really bizarre move justice
brett kavanaugh
joined with the majority of activist
justices but wrote separately that he
believed the cdc
had in fact exceeded its constitutional
authority
and that if they continued the
moratorium after the expiration date
he would vote to strike it down in other
words it was very clear
only congress not the white house can
enact legislation
ordering private landlords to forego
rent payments
the bulk of the constitutional
scholarship
says that it's not likely to pass
constitutional muster but there are
several
key scholars who think that it may
and it's worth the effort you heard that
biden knows that the supreme court will
rule that his action is on
unconstitutional but he's so scared of
the squad
that he'll extend a ban on evictions
anyway i'll just do it anyway
on grounds that did you hear that
several key scholars
think it could survive constitutional
muster now
is that the new standard for democrats
several scholars
can actually trump the supreme court
really i somehow must have missed that
in law school
the president would not have moved
forward with a step
where he didn't feel comfortable and
confident in the legal justification
he asked the cdc and his legal experts
to look at what is possible
this is a narrow targeted moratorium
that is different from the national war
term it's not an extension of that it's
a different moratorium
from a policy and legal standpoint
yeah and six is different from one half
dozen
that's just embarrassing this new and
targeted moratorium
applies to 90 of all rental properties
in the united states this is flagrant
lawlessness and it's
brought us to a moment of real peril in
this country
all because democrats again are
terrified of saying
no to the squad there's a huge victory
for the power of direct action and not
taking no
for an answer never has someone spouted
such gibberish so often with such
confidence
not taking no friends is she referring
to the white house
saying no or the supreme court saying no
is the standard now that
direct action overrules whatever the
constitution says
now remember these congresswoman
actually took an
oath to uphold the constitution when
they were sworn into office instead
they're trying to shred it yesterday's
street activists are today's
congressional reps
they don't feel constrained by anything
not by the supreme court not by laws
not by basic norms basic principles
they believe in governing by stunts
like camping on the capitol steps with a
lot of snacks
congresswoman corey bush a marxist blm
supporter
knew the democrats were weak knows
biden's weak so
she just demanded that biden get in line
get in line to prevent evictions for
rent cheats and he did
all we know is how to put our bodies on
the line in a moment like this and
that's that's what i learned from
ferguson ferguson taught me that
st louis taught me that show up stand up
sometimes
presence makes all the difference it
doesn't matter what you're faced with
what the adversity is
then it was rubber bullets real bullets
um white supremacist attacks
it was there were dogs you know tear gas
all of that
that we were fighting against while
trying to save black lives here
it was structures trying to be able to
break through structures
what structures does this woman want to
break through
without legislative authority what
happens when
aoc and corey bush tell biden that
workers
can never be fired is that a structure
that understanding that should just be
knocked down how about that businesses
of all sizes must pay for employee
health care
that no students have to pay back their
student loans
those structures that have to come down
one would think that our journalists and
our reporters
anyone with even a one iota
of a sense of fairness and reasonable
standards
might have some tough questions for
biden and the democrats about all of
this
like how on earth could the cdc
even have the authority to make
landlords go broke
or why doesn't congress raise this issue
on the floor
and actually try to do it the
old-fashioned way past legislation
or maybe what other supreme court
directives
do you plan on ignoring or have you
considered how devastating this will be
for first-time renters and poor people
landlords aren't going to want to rent
to them at all at this point
but no when the squad's involved
everything
is legal and just she's single-handedly
sitting on the capitol steps forced the
white house and democrats to push ahead
congresswoman
corey bush thank you so much for
lighting a fire under this so they did a
little dance
they're celebrating tonight
and they wonder why no one is watching
them
even if they don't care this is a real
constitutional crisis if a president
can just change any law he wants to
because a few legal scholars say oh it
might be okay
why do we even need a congress and we
already know nancy pelosi doesn't want
to force members of congress
to even return to d.c to have to vote
she just extended
proxy voting remember that was put in
place because of covin
so it all kind of works out perfectly
there is a silver lining here
we see who the democrats really are
it's aoc's party now there are no more
moderates they don't care about the
constitution or the people who suffer
from their lawlessness
i'm owed over 65 000 we can't take them
to court
we we still have to provide maintenance
it's coming right out of our pockets
systems designed to have the smaller
that smaller independent landlord to
give up
so many small landlords are behind
the washington post is reporting that
this moratorium could drive
thousands of landlords across the
country
into bankruptcy so what lessons should
we all learn from this
well first democrats only respect raw
power the supreme court should strike
down this biden scheme
and the vote should be 9-0 no more
needless dithering by justice kavanaugh
the voters have to rise up also in 2022
and end this entire fraudulent regime
that they're trying to impose on the
rest of us
because once there's no law and no
respect for the constitution
regular working people are going to be
completely shut out of the process
they're out of luck it's all about
whether you have connections or not
which sounds a heck of a lot the way
life like is like today in
a third world country or is that what
joe meant when he said
build back better and that's the end hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else